[Music]  Maksim Chmerkovskiy is saying sorry to  Vanessa Lachey 37 year old did not  perform with Vanessa on Mondays Dancing  with the Stars Jax is dealing with a  personal issue so Alan is stepping in  and dancing with Vanessa tonight max  took to Twitter on Wednesday writing in  part quote I take full responsibility  for my absence and want to apologize to  my partner Vanessa we are both looking  forward to dancing for our fans next  week  thesaurus previously told et that max  keep the show due to an ongoing conflict  with Vanessa adding that things  escalated and got heated this week et  was with the duo a weeks ago they were  in great spirits I really want to make  him proud and not let him down I just  wanted to make sure that all of his hard  work and our hard work was paying off no  one says it's your enough on the inside  [Music]  you  [Music]